[Music]
[Clapping]
[Music] It
's quick for the figure.
Chikage
I know
[Music]
Name This
is my
other person,
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
If you die here, Kagura will be
Mizukage.
[Music]
Ah ah ah
, if you're late
[Music]
This is a
succession of ninja techniques.
In fact, I just took a picture of everything I released using it.
It was amplified many times and I was struck by it
. A
simple story and you can absorb the art and release it.
Those souls are just  It's a consumable item that can be used up. If it's the
same mechanism as the forehead music reaction toy, the
story is quick.